O que que é melhor, probióticos ou mamps
de probióticos?
E aí, pessoal, hoje vamos conversar
sobre uma revolução silenciosa que está
acontecendo no mundo da saúde
intestinal. Uma descoberta que pode
mudar completamente a forma como
pensamos sobre probióticos e
imunomodulação. Estou falando os MAMPs,
os padrões moleculares associados aos
micróbios versus probióticos
tradicionais. Deixa eu começar com uma
analogia que vai facilitar o seu
entendimento. Imaginem que vocês querem
melhorar a segurança do prédio onde
moram. A abordagem tradicional seria
contratar seguranças vivos que precisam
se adaptar ao ambiente, conhecer as
regras locais e talvez nem sempre
consigam se estabelecer direito no
posto. Essa é a basicamente a estratégia
dos probióticos convencionais. Agora
imaginem uma segunda abordagem. Em vez
de depender de seguranças vivos, vocês
instalam sensores inteligentes que
detectam padrões específicos de ameaça e
ativam automaticamente o sistema de
segurança do prédio. Esses sensores não
precisam se adaptar, não morrem, não
competem entre si, eles simplesmente
fazem o que foram programados para
fazer. Essa é a essência dos mamps.
Vamos ao que a ciência mais recente tem
revelado sobre essa questão. Os mamps
são componentes moleculares estruturais
presentes em microrganismos, coisas como
lipopolissacarídos, flagelina,
peptidoglicanos, ácidos lipotecóicos.
São como assinaturas moleculares que
nosso sistema imune aprendeu a
reconhecer ao longo de milhares de anos
de evolução. O interessante é que essas
moléculas não precisam estar vivas para
funcionar. Elas são reconhecidas pelos
nossos receptores de reconhecimento
padrão, os famosos PRRs como os
receptores Tall e disparam com as cartas
de sinalização que modulam nossa
resposta imune de forma muito precisa.
Aqui é onde a coisa fica realmente
fascinante. Estudos de 2024 tem
demonstrado que preparações de mamps
purificados ou microorganismos
inativados pelo calor podem ter efeitos
imunomoduladores mais consistentes e
previsíveis que probióticos vivos. Sabe
por quê? Porque não depende da
colonização da sobrevivência no ambiente
ácido do estômago, da competição com
outras bactérias ou das variações
individuais do picobioma. Eu vou contar
para vocês um caso que me marcou muito.
Recebi um paciente com síndrome
intestino irritável que já havia tentado
cinco tipos diferentes em probióticos ao
longo de do anos. Sempre a mesma
história. Melhora inicial seguida de
retorno sintomas. Quando começamos a
trabalhar com abordagem baseada em MAMPS
através de pós bióticos específicos, a
resposta foi completamente diferente,
consistente, duradora, sem os altos e
baixos que ela experimentava antes. A
literatura científica atual mostra que
quando usamos MAMPS ou pós-bióticos, são
basicamente os produtos bioativos de
microrganismos fermentados, conseguimos
estimular vias específicas do sistema
imune sem depender da variabilidade
biológica de organismos vivos. É como
ter acesso direto aos interruptores do
sistema imune. Mas calma, não estou aqui
para demonizar os probióticos
tradicionais. Eles têm sim o seu lugar
na abordagem integrativa. A questão é
entender quando usar cada estratégia.
Probióticos vivos são excelentes para
recolonização após antibióticos para
pessoas saudáveis que querem manutenção
geral ou em situações onde precisamos
realmente de colonização intestinal. Os
mamps, por outro lado, brilham quando
queremos imunomodulação específica.
Quando lidamos com pacientes
imunocprometidos, onde probióticos vivos
podem ser arriscados, ou quando buscamos
efeitos mais previsíveis e padronizados.
É uma abordagem mais farmacológica,
digamos assim. Uma das vantagens dos
mampres é a estabilidade. Não precisamos
preocupar com refrigeração, prazo de
validade dos organismos vivos ou se as
bactérias vão sobreviver a passagem pelo
trato digestório. Os componentes
moleculares são muito mais estáveis e
resistentes. Outro ponto crucial é a
especificidade. Coms podemos mirar em
receptores específicos como TLR2, TLR4,
TLR5, TLR9, cada um com funções
distintas na resposta imune. É como ter
chaves específicas para diferentes
fechaduras do sistema imune em vez de
tentar abrir todas as portas com molho
de chaves aleatório.
A pesquisa 2024 publicada na C
metabolismos
demonstrou que pósicos derivados de
lactobacilos consegue modular a produção
de citocinas antiflamatórias de forma
mais eficiente que os organismos vivos
correspondentes. O interessante é que o
processo de inativação pelo calor até
potencializa alguns efeitos
imunomoduladores,
possivelmente pela liberação de proteías
de choque térmico. Mas vamos ser
honestos aqui. Essa tecnologia ainda
está em desenvolvimento. Os mamps, pós
bióticos são mais caros de produzir,
exige maior conhecimento técnico pela
formulação adequada e ainda não temos o
mesmo volume de estudos clínicos que
temos para postbióticos ou probióticos
tradicionais. Na minha prática clínica,
tenho usado uma abordagem escalonada.
Para pacientes com questões simples de
saúde intestinal, começamos com
probiótico de qualidade, fermentados
naturais e mudanças dietéticas. Para
casos mais complexos, especialmente
aqueles envolvendo desregulação
imunológica ou inflamação crônica, os
mamps têm se mostrado uma ferramenta
muito mais potente. O futuro
provavelmente está em formulações
híbridas, combinações inteligentes de
probióticos vivos para colonização,
prebióticos para alimentar os residentes
benéficos e mamps específicos para
imunomodulação direcionada. é o que
alguns pesquisadores estão chamando de
simbióticos de quarta geração. Uma coisa
que me empolga muito nessa área é a
possibilidade de personalização. Com os
avanços em análise do microbiôme de
pagem de receptores imunológicos,
podemos estar caminhando para uma era
onde saberemos exatamente quais mamps
usar para cada perfil individual. É
medicina de precisão aplicada ao
microbioma, mas não podemos esquecer o
básico. Nem mamps, nem probióticos fazem
milagres se continuarmos com dieta
processada sobre ruim, estresse crônico
e exposição constante a toxinas. A base
continua sendo um estilo de vida que
honre nossa biologia ancestral. A
mensagem que quero deixar hoje é essa.
Estamos entrando numa nova era da
imunomodulação intestinal. Os mant
representam uma evolução natural da
nossa compressão sobre o nosso sistema
imunológico e o microbioma. como eles se
comunicam, não é questão de substituir
probióticos ou mamps, mas sim de
entender quando cada ferramenta é mais
apropriada. Para quem está começando
essa jornada de saúde intestinal,
probióticos de qualidade, mudança
dietética são excelente ponto de
partida. Para quem já está nessa
caminhada faz tempo e tem buscado
resultados mais específicos ou para caso
mais complexo, os MAMPs abrem
possibilidades terapêuticas muito
interessantes. O importante é lembrar
que não existe pala de prata na saúde. A
abordagem funcional sempre vai ser
sobreentender a individualidade
bioquímica de cada pessoa e usar as
ferramentas certas no momento certo. Os
mantis são mais uma ferramenta muito
promissora, por sinal, no nosso arsenal
terapêutico. A revolução da saúde
intestinal está apenas começando e vocês
estão aqui para acompanhar essa jornada
incrível de descobertas que estão
mudando essa forma de enxergar a
interação entre microorganismos e saúde
humana. Ah.